just like we computed the XY position of
the tile index for our Atlas we can use
the same math magic to determine what
position in the world X and worldwide we
need to draw this tile we change the
numbers right given the tile index we
modulate it by the number of X tiles and
divided by the number of X tiles times
by the tile size to give us our pixel
offsets in the world from there we go
back to our accelerated draw image API
that passes the image X Y in the source
tile size and tile X in the source and
then where we would like to draw it in
the world x and y notice the tile size
for the source and the destination are
identical here this means we'd actually
like to draw a 64 pixel by 64 pixel
Atlas image to represent a 64 pixel by
64 pixel image inside of our world